democracy democracy Call of Duty
advanced future Kevin Spacey is upon you
and your Katie needs some polish sure
you played Call of Duty's pass but that
one won at the end of every round is
eating you inside chances are you're
making some pretty common mistakes so
we're here with the top 5 tips that can
make you better at shooters number one
watch pro gamers differently
most people are blinded by pro gamers
raw aiming prowess and fast reflexes but
what they're actually not seeing is
their savage situational awareness and
great movement making decisions pros
constantly read the map looking for
enemy pushes and blind spots waiting for
numbers advantages timing transitions
between objectives and most importantly
backing away from doom plays the new
exosuit and its abilities in advanced
warfare besides just looking snazzy our
would actually allow you to execute
quickly on those critical movement
decisions now stop watching professional
gamers because you're really never gonna
be that good but then do watch yourself
play by streaming to twitch and watching
your own archives you'd be amazed how
much you can learn
number two trickery and anticipation a
common scenario is you spot an enemy
play across the map they duck behind
cover before you can get a shot off or
your weapon didn't have a long enough
range and you bit the shot did the enemy
player go left right up or down
it's a very simple question but will
probably determine if you win or lose
the vast majority of your 1v1
engagements well nine times out of ten
that player did see you and is faking
one direction before doubling back and
shooting at you from the other side of
the map it's one of the oldest tricks in
the book and it's amazing how many
players use it and still fall for it
anticipating the double back can give
you a fighting chance and increase your
odds of a win if you win that gunfight
now anticipate the double double back
number three master the rhythm a rhythm
is something like in halo nade shoot
punch every game has a rhythm a sequence
of well-timed well-rehearsed actions
that increase your odds of winning in
Call of Duty score streaks usually play
a big role in these rhythms so finding
ones that work for you and learning how
to consistently use them will play a big
role in your success mode and map rhythm
is also included in this category
for example in domination players will
tend to capture a point and consistently
go for an adjacent point remembering the
time it takes to get between objectives
will allow you to set up for a fast
ambush one of the best ways to master a
rhythm is to play a mode that lets you
repeatedly run up the same side of a map
over and over and over again until you
have it memorized
number four cornering Call of Duty is a
game with fast movement and faster death
it's hard enough to win 1v1 engagements
much less 1v2
you want to use the corners of buildings
and obstacles to cut off your line of
sight so that you only ever see one
enemy player at a time this involves not
punching into rims too deeply when
charging forward and backing off around
corners when confronted with more than
one opposing player on a side note if
you're on a corner and an enemy runs by
you make sure you wait a second or pop
that EXO ping to see if he has friends
because you don't want to get shot in
the back and that brings us to number
five
don't force a load out for XP or chivos
nothing will get you killed faster than
forcing a shotgun outside of its
effective range or running up the sniper
side of a map with an SMG yes you want
that next cam full of supplies and you
do need them buckshot kills to get there
but you're Katy doesn't have to suffer
for it
use the EXO ability ping to pick fights
that you can win also with weapons that
take a while to reload learn not to hit
the reload button on reflex rather
switch to a secondary until it's safe
well those were our top 5 tips to help
you improve your KD we're curious to
hear what you have to say about the
newest cod Edition and how the EXO
abilities change or maybe don't change
rounds for you until next time there now
you